we're taking it up a level that we have
in years past and it's um
you can just tell from the coaches
excitement um
to their attention to detail to how guys
are um reacting to their coaching uh
this this team is going to be awesome
anything we want to do man i mean you
name it man we got four two four three
maybe four one i don't know what tyrique
runs now who knows but he uh we we got
guys that can absolutely fly all over
the field and speed kills in this game
travis kelsey says the chiefs are taking
the offense up a level and we're taking
it up a level on today's pft live draft
the coin toss i don't want to say it's
done
it's been temporarily suspended while we
have a different device for determining
the first pick today's draft obviously
the best offenses for 2019 so chris what
we have decided to try out here is a
trivia question now we have to work a
little bit on the details of how we
handle the trivia question for example
control room specifically stats don't
put the trivia question in the sheets if
i have a chance to ask the trivia
question he's got six minutes to google
an answer i didn't google it i promise
i'm sure you didn't i promise i'm sure
you didn't i
all right here's the question the chief
scored 565 points last season how many
teams have ever scored more points in a
single season and i specifically
made it easier for you instead of asking
the specific number or the teams i'm
just giving you the over under is it
over under 1.5 i i you know and i almost
a little embarrassed that i don't know
this really off the top of my head and i
really have no clue here i'm not going
to say it's many i'm gonna go with the
over as it being like two
that sounds yeah you're right yeah you
win you get the first pick yeah good job
who what who who are the two though does
anybody want to tell me that
i i don't know i had it but now it's
gone 2013 broncos okay more and
and the 2007 patriots well that makes a
lot of sense yeah okay so there you have
it okay i'm going first as usual i like
it and i will choose the kansas city
chiefs shock
we should have had we should have had
every every offense but the chiefs but
go ahead and get the chiefs how could i
not pick them uh the the offense andy
reed's aggressiveness the talent they
have the damn quarterback is a absolute
just much must watch freak of nature
i mean just the way they play yes and
and again yeah there's okay maybe a
little questions at the running back
situation but not really i mean when
damien williams healthy he proved he's
capable of being a really good nfl
running back good offensive line and
something we talked about you know
earlier mike it is year two for patrick
mahomes and even though last year was
amazing you know i know you've heard me
say there was plays that were left on
the field uh in a number of games even
though the stats were awesome and that's
scary and i just think they're not going
to manage them as much there's going to
be more of a trust and just hey let's
put more offense in let's do more
concepts let's let them be aggressive we
don't have to worry about that now he
knows how to play and what to expect so
i go chiefs
yeah
you didn't even need to explain it
chiefs we all know chiefs chief's best i
mean and
there's no reason to even expect any
type of a letdown from this team they
are going to take it next level and it
was just so
so obvious in their preseason opener
that this team is already where it needs
to be for the regular season they look
as good as they did in the regular
season and patrick mahomes the same guy
that he was a year ago if anybody had
any doubts he's the same guy all right i
i'm gonna stay in the conference but not
in the division if baker mayfield is
gonna tell us the hype is real i'm gonna
believe him and the hype is real baker
mayfield jarvis landry otto beckham jr
david njoku nick chubb
kareem hunt once his suspension ends
yeah i know the offensive line isn't
dominant but it doesn't need to be get
rid of the ball quickly and off you go
and i think that offense in cleveland
has the potential to be spectacular it
just could have could you imagine how
good that offense would be if they
played in a dome right um same thing for
the chiefs too but i think the browns
are going to be an exciting offense i
don't know if they're going to be in the
top five all-time in yardage or points
but they're going to be fun to watch
because they're going to be able to
score any time any place anywhere one of
the things last year you pointed about
the chiefs chris is that you have to
defend the whole field right when you
were going against the chiefs and i
think that's going to be true of this
year's browns you're going to have to
defend the whole field if you take away
otto beckham jr jarvis landry is going
to kill you underneath you take away the
run beckham's going to kill you over the
top mayfield is going to be able to
throw it pretty much anywhere and he's
going to lead that team consistently to
points and yardage and we'll see how
many wins go along with it a lot of it's
going to depend on what the defense can
do yep uh totally i mean this is another
one i think it's a no-brainer these were
the top two picks i mean because of the
quarterback because the weapons on the
outside because of the coaches and the
aggressive nature of their play calling
and like you said having to defend the
whole field uh the the cleveland browns
are a little different than kansas city
and the fact that i do think they'll
have more semblance of a run game right
but uh i'm with you that was that was a
no-brainer so they're gone
now round two
this is where
it gets a little dicey there's a lot of
options here i don't know where to go
exactly but i think i'm gonna go i mean
we're going for who will be the best
offenses and i'm gonna go with a team
that was number two in offense last year
and i think they're gonna be better and
that's the tampa bay buccaneers now i
don't know if that translates to wins it
might not but i know bruce arians is
there and it's going to be bombs away
and they got mike evans and they got
chris godwin who might not be mainstream
household name quite yet but he is very
good and going to be very capable of
creating a niche in the offense there
for bruce ariens oj howard at tight end
you're hearing good things about ronald
jones at running back i think he's going
to be a big factor in the past game
coming out of the backfield and then
they do have peyton barber who i think
is one of the more underrated
running backs in all of football so i
think i look at that jameis winston is a
phenomenal intermediate to deep ball
thrower and that fits bruce aryans and
one other factor is i'm just not sure
about their defense there might be a lot
of games where they're down by 10 in the
fourth quarter or down by seven in the
fourth quarter and they have to throw
more and put more stats on the board and
that's why i'm going to buccaneers
yeah you know i have them on my list
they may have been my third pick i'm
kind of glad you took them now i was
nervous you were going to take the team
that i really considered making my first
pick but if i had you would have been
all over the browns in round two so i
went brown's round one and i held until
round two you're philadelphia oh
i am convinced that offense is going to
be phenomenal this year they got jordan
howard from the bears they stole him and
i know they have a whole stable of
running backs but that's good right
jordan howard's talented you put
somebody else in uh if he's not getting
it done if you just want to have the
variety they've got guys there that can
get it done at every position they've
got desean jackson back you put him
together with carson wentz carson wentz
hasn't had that consistent deep threat
and they love desean jackson in
philadelphia they're already building
the chemistry i think this can be a
special special offense you got al shawn
jeffrey trying to redeem himself for
what happened last year in that playoff
game when he dropped the pass at a time
when it looked like the eagles were
going to knock off the saints i i just
think a healthy carson wentz is the key
but i love the philadelphia eagles
offense they can get back to and the
only caveat is this chris
don't get so smitten with what wence can
do that you get away from the meat and
potatoes still run the ball
run the ball run the ball but then when
it's time to to have that lightning
strike desean jackson's going to be
there deep al sean jeffrey is going to
be there at an intermediate level you've
still got zach ertz getting it done
dallas goddard coming into his own
hopefully for the eagle's sake as a
tight end option and that this can be a
great offense in 2019. ah
man that hurt me i just you're just uh a
little smarter than you look i just was
not expecting you to go there i was
really i was sandbagging that that was
the second pick that was i just didn't
think you were smart enough to come up
with it i really didn't and you're i
don't know whether i don't know whether
to be
uh happy or insulted about that yeah i'd
be insane
i'm a little insulted it was an insult
don't worry there's no doubt about it i
was insulting you for sure um
is it safe to say you self-outsmarted
yourself i sell how smart of this you
see when you scout your scout yourself
and the opponent too much you can you
know too many too many things going on
your brain and yeah that really messed
me up because i just did not think you
were going to go there i thought you oh
he's on the ropes he's buying time and
now you want to transparent no i'm going
to be transparent it's the 49ers the
colts the falcons those are all teams
i'm looking at right there uh that are
in the conversation for best offenses
and i think i'm going to go with the
atlanta falcons you know the 49ers i'm
just not quite sure about jimmy
garoppolo the colts the andrew luck
thing scares me just a little bit uh i
know that matt ryan is johnny
consistency and he's been playing really
good football the last two years and
calvin ridley being in year two um was
much better as a rookie than i gave him
credit for coming out in the draft uh i
i know he's a stud you know my brother
that's one of the first things he
brought up about the atlanta falcons man
this calvin ridley so i thought that was
just you know that that made my ears
perk up a little bit as well but then
when muhammad sanu was your third
receiver and devonte freeman and dirk
cutters there all of those things i just
look at that as a pretty damn good unit
right there that can put up a lot of
points in yards
you know there's a lot to choose from at
this point especially because i'm
stunned you took the falcons and and i
i'm tempted i'm tempted to to go you
know kind of curveball and say this
vikings offense with gary kubiak there
and you know without all the adversity
they went through last year they lost
line coach tony sperano right before
training camp and and john d filippo had
the offense all screwed up because he
was trying to to parlay that gig into a
head coaching job and they didn't run
the ball the way they should i'm just go
look we're down to number six yeah right
right and at numbers how can you not
have the same the the los angeles rams
or the st louis rams on the list that's
the first time i've done that they moved
four years ago the la rams at at round
three yeah i still don't think they're
gonna be what they were last year right
but i also think that all this noise out
there about todd gurley and jared goff
and has the rest of the league caught up
to sean mcvay they're going to get
pissed off at some point
and they're going to take it out on some
people and also having a great defense
and i think the defense is still going
to be great if not better than it was
last year
i think that uh that helps the offense
even more and uh you know
maybe not the chiefs level maybe not the
browns level but still good enough to be
in this conversation and i'm kind of
stunned you didn't even bring that up as
you were rattling off your choices for
your third round they they are on my
longer list but i i guess the the way
the year ended and the offense kind of
sputtering down the stretch to a degree
uh and especially the passing game you
know other than really the saints game
who just probably played they played too
much man-to-man in that game in general
yeah i guess they just left a bad taste
in my mouth and and i do i want to see
how they're going to reinvent themselves
they became a little product predictable
teams crack the code on them a little
bit i mean there's still a lot of talent
a lot of what you said is true there but
that's what made me chicken out
i still think they're good enough to be
number six i i just i yeah i'm not gonna
disagree with that and and the fact the
fact that we would have them that low
and you had them on your longer list
that's just kind of not that they're
paying attention to what we're saying
but that's the kind of thing that
contributes to this vibe out there this
negative vibe that they can use to avoid
the complacency that would set in for a
team that made it to the super bowl lost
and now has to go back to zero and zero
and have that target on the back they
don't have the same target on their back
that a super bowl team would have
because we all assume the offense isn't
going to be as good all right chris's
picks chiefs buccaneers falcons i've got
the browns eagles and the rams the best
offenses in 2019. we'll put this on the
website and get your thoughts later in
the day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports